sehr geehrte Frau Bundestagspräsidentin
der Bundeskanzler sehr geehrter Herr
Bundesratspräsident Exzellenzen heute
insbesondere sehr verehrte Botschafter
mathilf
verehrte Abgeordnete liebe Gäste
meine Damen und Herren die hätten ist
ein Straßendorf irgendwo zwischen
ein Dorf wie viele andere dort in der
nordukraine klein unauffällig
ohne jede militärische Bedeutung
ich werde diesen Ort niemals vergessen
im Oktober war ich dort
und was mir die Menschen über ihr
maturium erzählt haben
[Musik]
das hat sich ewig in mein Gedächtnis
eingebrannt
wenige Tage nach dem Überfall der EU
keine
hatten Soldaten der russischen Armee in
Ort besetzt sie nahmen
die Einwohner gefangen
sperrten sie in den Keller der kleinen
Dorfschule mehr als 300 Menschen auf
engstem Raum
darunter Kranke ganz alte auch 20 Kinder
das jüngste gerade mal
anderthalb Monate alt
dort kauerten sie auf dem Boden den
Dunkelheit und Kälte
fast ohne Essen ohne Toiletten 28 lange
Tage und Nächte
und die ersten der alten starben
13 von ihnen überlebten den Keller nicht
aber die Toten nach draußen zu tragen
das blieb ihnen verboten und so mussten
die Kinder im Keller
zwischen den Leichen der Verstorbenen
spielen
als mir die Männer des Dorfes diese
Geschichte erzählt haben kam mir in die
trennen
in Erinnerung an das Leid an die
Demütigungen
und die Frauen kannten gar nicht
sprechen über das
was ihnen außerhalb des Kellers angetan
worden war
ein Beispiel ich weiß
aber es war und ist der Alltag in großen
Teilen der Ukraine jeden Tag sterben
unschuldige Menschen werden
Mütter zu widmen
und Kinder zu weisen jeden Tag trägt
Russland unermessliches Leid
in die Ukraine und auch ein Jahr nach
Beginn des russischen Überfalls auf die
Ukraine geht dieser Krieg weiter mit
unverminderter Härte weiter es gibt
keine Worte für den Schmerz und die
Grausamkeit die Millionen Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer erleben wenn Sie Ihre
Liebsten betrauern
wenn sie bei jedem Luftalarm um ihr
eigenes Leben fürchten
wenn sie bei Eis und Schnee in den
Schützengräben ausharren
heute am Jahrestag der russischen
Invasion hier bei dieser
gemeinsamen Veranstaltung mit der
Ukraine
sind Menschen unter uns die
unvorstellbares erlebt haben
die Hölle die ich durchgemacht habe
sie kann von niemandem geträumt werden
sagten sie liebe Frau
nachdem sie den verzweifelten Kampf um
mariopol und die Belagerung in den
Katakomben von asus-
wir alle
erinnern uns an das kurze Video aus den
Katakomben dass sie zeigt wie sie dort
sitzen mit so vielen Frauen und Männern
ohne Nahrung und Medikamente und am Ende
ohne Munition
und dann ist da ihre Stimme
und sie singen sie singen vom Kampf für
die Freiheit ihres Landes
viele Millionen nur keinerinnen und
Ukrainer stellen sich jeden Tag ihren
russischen Angreifern entgegen ihr aller
Mut der Mut ihre Freiheit und ihre
Unabhängigkeit zu verteidigen
er ist da und er hat ganz große Kraft
diese Männer und Frauen bangen täglich
um ihr Leben und um Ihre Liebsten aber
sie kämpfen auch täglich für ihr Land
und ihre Freiheit
wir Deutsche wir bewundern den Mut die
Kraft und den Willen der Menschen der
Ukraine und wir stehen in Solidarität in
ihrer Seite
wir helfen Ihnen sich zu verteidigen wir
nehmen Anteil
an ihren millionenfachen leid und wir
trauern um ihre Toten liebe Gäste
ich möchte Sie bitten gemeinsam mit mir
einen Moment inne zu halten um der Opfer
des russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine zu gedenken und dazu möchte ich
Sie bitten sich zu erheben
vielen Dank
meine Damen und Herren der Krieg ist
zurück in Europa zum ersten Mal seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg findet mitten in
Europa wieder in Eroberungsfeldzug statt
Russland spricht der Ukraine das
Existenzrecht ab will die Ukraine als
eigenständige Nation vernichten
die Unverletzlichkeit von Grenzen
die Souveränität und Selbstbestimmung
eines Landes
Menschenwürde und Frieden die Einhaltung
von Regeln und recht
das bedeutet Putin nichts alles worauf
unser Zusammenleben in Europa aufgebaut
ist
zählt für ihn nicht
es zählt aber für uns
Deutschland ist nicht im Krieg aber
dieser Krieg geht uns an der russische
Überfall hat uns in eine überwunden
geglaubte Zeit gestürzt Russlands
Angriffskrieg hat die europäische
sicherheitsordnung in Schutt und Asche
gelegt er ist ein Angriff auf alle
Lehren die die Welt aus zwei Weltkriegen
gezogen hat er ist ein Angriff
auf all das für das auch wir stehen
das macht den
Epochenbruch aus den wir gegenwärtig
erleben
die neue Zeit meine Damen und Herren
stellt neue Fragen
und nicht alle Antworten finden wir in
der Vergangenheit nicht in den Routinen
der letzten Jahrzehnte
für uns für die Länder der Europäischen
Union waren dies Jahrzehnte von
Stabilität und Wachstum und davon war
unser Denken und davon war unser Handeln
geprägt
heute müssen wir anders denken und an
das Handeln
es versteht sich von selbst dass wir
finanzielle und wirtschaftliche Hilfe
leisten für das überfallen
das mehr als eine Million nur
keinerinnen und Ukrainer bei uns
Zuflucht gefunden haben und ich bin
allen deutschen allen Menschen in
unserem Land dankbar dass sie sich in so
großer Zahl für die Opfer dieses Krieges
einsetzen Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
unterstützen
Partnergemeinden in der Ukraine helfen
und das auch weiterhin tun werden
anders zu denken und anders zu handeln
in dieser neuen Zeit bedeutet dass wir
jetzt auch Entscheidungen treffen die
wir vor ein zwei Jahren vielleicht noch
für unvorstellbar gehalten haben wir
liefern Waffen in ein Kriegsgebiet
schwere Waffen wir unterstützen die
Ukraine in einem militärischen nie
dagewesenen Ausmaß
mit großer Anstrengung mit großem Ernst
natürlich ist jede Entscheidung
begleitet von großen auch emotionalen
Eskalation bei den einen
von Ungeduld bei den Anderen
eines weiß ich meine Damen und Herren
die politischen Verantwortungsträger
die hier vor mir sitzen in Regierung wie
in Opposition
sie sind sich der großen Tragweite jeder
einzelne Entscheidung sehr bewusst
sie bewerten und entscheiden in
Verantwortung für unser Land
für unser Bündnis
und für die Ukraine und ich meine dafür
verdienen sie Respekt und Vertrauen
Deutschland
ist heute auch militärisch der größte
Unterstützer der Ukraine auf dem
europäischen Kontinent und bei allen
Kontroversen und manchmal schrillen
Debatten bin ich sicher wir werden das
auch weiterhin sein deshalb sage ich
Herr Botschafter auch mit Blick auf das
was noch vor uns liegt
auf Deutschland ist Verlass die
mädchener
gesehen unsere Demokratie stark viel
stärker als Putin sich vorgestellt hat
und stärker auch als wir vielleicht
manchmal selbst geglaubt haben
Putin setzt darauf dass die Verbündeten
der Ukraine irgendwann müde werden dass
wir
abstumpfen und wegschauen werden
angesichts der Schreckens der ja eine
Schreckens der auch für uns schwer
auszuhalten ist diesen gefallen meine
Damen und Herren diesen Gefallen werden
wir ihnen diesen Gefallen werden wir
Putin nicht tun
ja unsere Entschlossenheit und unsere
Geschlossenheit werden noch auf lange
Zeit gefordert sein wir unterstützen die
Ukraine auf dem Weg in die Europäische
Union ein Weg der eng verbundenes mit
dem Wiederaufbau des geschundenen Landes
und wir wissen dass die Ukraine auf
lange Sicht auch nach diesem Krieg eine
starke Verteidigung und wirksame
Sicherheitsgarantien auf all das
angewiesen sein wird auch dafür stehen
wir an ihrer Seite verehrter markiert
die Ukraine kämpft um ihr Land ihre
Freiheit und die Zukunft in Europa
sie kämpft gegen Landraub und Besatzung
sie kämpft für das was jedes Land dieser
Welt für sich in Anspruch nimmt für das
mit anderen Worten was Voraussetzung für
einen gerechten und einen dauerhaften
Frieden ist
in Frieden
den Frieden der sehnen sich viele
Menschen in diesen Tagen in unserem Land
weltweit aber nirgends so sehr wie in
der Ukraine selbst
doch ein
scheinfriede der nur Putins Land braucht
besiegelt und die Menschen im übrigen
der Wilke der Besatzer überlässt
so ein Friede wird kein Friede sein
eine überwältigende Mehrheit der Staaten
in den Vereinten Nationen hat gestern
bekräftigt wenn Friede einkehren soll
dann muss es ein gerechter und
dauerhafter Friede sein
jeder konstruktive Vorschlag der uns auf
dem Weg zum gerechten Frieden
näherbringt ist hoch willkommen
ob die Welt nach China eine solche
konstruktive Rolle spielen will
ist noch fraglich wenn dem so ist dann
sollte ich China jedenfalls nicht nur
mit Moskau sprechen sondern auch mit
Kiew wenn dem so ist dann sollte ich
China sich der überwältigenden Mehrheit
der Staaten anschließen und unter dem
Dach der Vereinten Nationen für Frieden
eintreten und wenn dem so ist dann
müssen wir gemeinsam die Prinzipien der
Vereinten Nationen dort behaupten wo sie
Tag für Tag gebrochen werden es ist
nämlich Russland dass er Nachbarland
brutal überfallen hat und es ist
Russland das immer neue Truppen an die
Front wirft nicht die westliche
verteidigungshilfe verlängert den Krieg
es ist Russland nicht die Ukraine und
ihre Verbündeten verweigern sich dem
Frieden
es ist Russland
Putin weiß sehr genau was zu tun ist
wenn er ernsthaft ein Ende des Krieges
wollte
erst wenn die wenn sich russische
Truppen zurückziehen öffnet das den Weg
zu Verhandlungen so fordert es die
Resolution der Vereinten Nationen
gestern
Russland meine Damen und Herren muss
unmissverständlich klar werden es kann
keinen Sieg geben in seinem
verbrecherischen Krieg
putin will siegen
will Segen mit aller Macht aber die
Wahrheit ist
wer Morden und töten lässt wer die
Ukraine
kaputtbomben Städte zerstören Kinder
verschleppen lässt
wer selbst die eigenen Soldaten Tag und
Tag sinnlos verbluten lässt
wer wird
der wird vor der Geschichte niemals als
Sieger da stehen
der hat schon verloren
meine Damen und Herren sie alle haben
vorhin
sie haben beim Hereinkommen in diesen
Raum die Fotografien in der Galerie
unten gesehen
die Trümmer einer Wohnung in
die Trümmer eines Hauses im Donbass ist
einmal zu Hause seiner Bewohner war
ein kleiner Junge am Grab seiner Mutter
in Butcher
und sie haben vielleicht auch das letzte
das zentrale Foto in dieser Ausstellung
gesehen es zeigt einen Soldaten
in einem Dorf vor
in seinen Armen eine Frau
die beiden sind einfach froh einander am
Leben zu sehen
erschöpft
aber befreit
der Frieden
hier blitzt der für einen Augenblick auf
ich wünsche mir
dass wir noch viele bilder wie dieses
Sehen herzlichen Dank
geht
[Applaus]
liebes deutsches Volk lieber Herr
Bundespräsident lieber Herr Kanzler
lieber Olaf heute ist es ein Jahr her
seit sich alles geändert hat für die
Ukraine für Deutschland für ganz Europa
und für die freie Welt das woran sich
die freie Welt in 10 Jahrzehnten des
Friedens gewöhnt hatte erwies sich als
etwas wofür man kämpfen muss
die Diplomatie hat nicht funktioniert
die bestehende Sicherheitsarchitektur
der Welt ist gescheitert die alte
europäische Hoffnung das wirtschaftliche
Beziehungen russische panzerkörnern
aufhalten könnten ist nicht aufgegangen
aber es gab auch etwas was funktionierte
vor allem die Einheit die Einheit der
Ukraine Deutschlands und der ganzen
freien Welt
und die Entschlossenheit die
Entschlossenheit die Grundlagen unseres
gemeinsamen Lebens zu verteidigen wir
kämpfen auf ukrainischem Boden für das
ohne dass sie alle liebe Freunde sich
ihr eigenes Leben nicht vorstellen
können das ist elementare Sicherheit das
sind Freiheit und leben nach Gesetzen
das sind Menschenwürde und das Recht
jedes Menschen und jeder Gemeinschaft
beachtet zu werden das sind das Glück in
einer Familie zu leben und die
Möglichkeit von einer sicheren und
freien Zukunft für die eigenen Kinder zu
träumen es sind einfache Dinge
derzeit
1.877 ukrainische Städte und Dörfer
beraubt sind die Besatzer wollen diese
Zahlen noch erhöhen und zu den
zerbrochenen
schicksalm noch Millionen weitere
hinzufügen wissen Sie in unserem von
Russland besetzen gibt es fast keine
intakten Häuser mehr russland hat alles
getan um diese Stadt zu töten
eins lebten dort fast eine halbe Million
Menschen
ist zu mehr als 90% zerstört die
Überreste von Häusern die durch
russische Bomben und Raketen zerstört
wurden
niedergebrannte Teile der Stadt werden
von den Besatzern abgetragen
um diese schrecklichen Ruinen in Beton
Schotter zu verwandeln
der für den Bau von Straßen verwandelt
werden soll
wir müssen alles mögliche und unmögliche
dafür tun es Russland nicht zu erlauben
die Ukraine unsere Nachbarn und ganz
Europa
nachdem der russische revanismus greifen
will in betonschotter zu verwandeln
haben wir die Kraft bewegen ja wir sind
in der Lage dazu in Einheit entschieden
und standhaft wir sind in der Lage schon
in diesem Jahr der russischen Aggression
ein Ende zu bereiten von den ersten
Minuten der russischen Invasion an in
Deutschland mit uns
Deutschland hilft uns die Ukraine vor
russischen Terror zu schützen und
Deutschland wird am Tage des Sieges der
Freiheit mit uns sein es wird mit uns
sein wenn wir unsere derzeit besetzen
Städte und Dörfer aus der russischen
Sklaverei befreien wird retten werden
deutsches Volk Herr Bundespräsident Herr
Kanzler
jetzt ist die Zeit wo man mit unserem
Mord und unseren Waffen
Frieden wiederherstellen und eine
historisch wichtige Sicherung gegen
jegliche Aggressionen schaffen kann
niemand wird mir eine Aggression gegen
eine andere Nation wagen wenn er weiß
dass die freie Welt diese Nation
verteidigen wird niemand wird mehr die
Freiheit angreifen wenn er weiß dass die
freie Welt entschlossen genug ist die
Freiheit zu verteidigen niemand wird den
24 Februar
des letzten Jahres mehr wiederholen wenn
er weiß
auf dem gesamten Territorium der Ukraine
kein einziger Besatzer geblieben ist
dafür können wir sorgen zusammen mit
Ihnen zusammen mit allen auf der Welt
die das Leben schätzen
ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Unterstützung
danke dass ihr dieses Jahr mit uns waren
danke Ihnen Herr Bundespräsident danke
dir Olaf für Vertrauen in die Ukraine in
unsere Bürger und in unsere gemeinsamen
Werte eines freien vereinten Europas
Akademie
[Musik]
sie interpretieren ein Stück das
ukrainischen Komponisten miroslavik der
Titel lautet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gehörte einordnen mit Theo Koll der
jetzt bei mir ist Leiter des ZDF
Hauptstadtstudios diese Veranstaltung
heute hier im Schloss Bellevue am
Jahrestag des russischen Angriffs war
Steinmeier ganz persönlich ein wichtiges
Anliegen welche Bedeutung hat dieser
Termin
ich glaube das ist ein hohes Maß an
Solidarität das heute gezeigt werden
soll von der gesamten deutschen
Staatsspitze und in einem persönlichen
Sinne ist es sicherlich auch ein
erneutes klarmachen von Steinmeier
seines Bruchs mit seiner früheren eher
Russland freundlichen Positionen der hat
das ja in verschiedenen reden schon klar
gemacht aber heute das war auch noch mal
ganz klares Signal
gegen Russland und für die Ukraine wie
bewerten Sie die Rede Steinmeiers und
die Botschaft des selenskys ich fand es
hoch interessant a ist Steinmeier ja
konkret auf die Vorschläge der Chinesen
eingegangen die waren ja schon auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
angekündigt worden dass man einen
Friedensplan Friedensverhandlungen
vorschlagen würde nun gibt es diese 12
Punkte Programm der Chinesen und er hat
im Grunde sehr deutlich gesagt er hält
sie
ersetzt ein großes Fragezeichen ob China
wirklich ein konstruktiver
friedensvermittler sein kann und müsse
die un-prinzipien anerkennen was China
ja nicht gemacht hat in dem Sinne sie
haben sich ja nicht der UN Resolution
angeschlossen in New York und insofern
hat er gesagt da so wenn dann müssen die
un-prinzipien eingehalten werden also
hat sehr aktuelle reagiert auf China und
ich fand interessant dass er nach vorne
geschaut hat übrigens ja auch silensky
und hat gesagt so wir sind nicht nur
jetzt an eurer Seite sondern wir werden
auch dafür sorgen dass ihr künftig eine
starke Verteidigung habt und ihr braucht
Sicherheitsgarantien auch da werden wir
in eurer Seite sein als Deutschland
zuletzt hat die drei Parteien für
ampelregierung wurden dabei Europa
sicherheitsordnung ja noch einigermaßen
intakt was hat der Krieg mit der
Bundesregierung gemacht
er hat mit uns allen wahnsinnig viel
gemacht und ich glaube er wird noch sehr
viel mehr mit uns machen und uns unsere
Welt verändern die Ampel ist ja
angetreten mit dem Koalitionsvertrag
mehr Fortschritt Wagen und im Grunde
leben sie jetzt in einer Welt mehr
Wagnis im Wagnis voranschreiten denn sie
sind in einer völlig anderen Welt also
die zeitenwände die Olaf Scholz
verkündet hat drei Tage nach
Kriegsausbruch Steinmeier nennt es ja so
gar noch größer den Epochenbruch hat und
wird unsere Welt verändern und ähm die
Ampel hat im Prinzip jetzt sich
verändert von einer
fortschrittskoalition diese sein wollte
zu einem Krisenmanager genau diese
historische Rede damals drei Tage nach
Kriegsbeginn als scheut das erste mal
den Begriff Zeitenwende benutzte wie
wird das heute in Berlin diskutiert
dauert die Zeiten wenn du noch an oder
war das damals im Februar eine Art
Gegenwartsdiagnose
ich glaube das ist eine gegenwarts- und
zukunftsdiagnose diese zeitenwände heißt
wir sind in einer anderen Welt und
vieles davon ist uns glaube ich noch gar
nicht so klar denn wir haben natürlich
im Moment in diesem Krisenmanagement ja
wir spüren Inflation wir spüren die
Energiepreise sind höher aber vieles
wurde mit staatlichen Geldern abgefangen
und
das wird glaube ich unser gesamtes sein
viel deutlicher verändern als uns das im
Moment schon klar ist wir haben ja
Deutschland war ja im Grunde immer auf
drei Säulen gebaut wir hatten die
amerikanische Sicherheit wir hatten
preiswertes billiges russisches Öl oder
Energie und wir hatten China als
Handelspartner der unseren Wohlstand mit
Sicherheit und da sind riesige
Fragezeichen entstanden die Energie aus
Russland ist bleiben weg und China
wissen wir alle von denen sind wir
unglaublich abhängig und müssen uns
unabhängiger machen auch das ist eine
Frage die unseren wohl stand natürlich
groß betreffen wird Berlin wurde ja oft
als zu zögerlich wahrgenommen auch beim
Thema Panzerlieferungen das wird aber
nicht die letzte Belastungsprobe gewesen
sein also was kommt da noch zu auf die
Bundesregierung und auch auf die
Gesellschaft
die Diskussion laufen natürlich also
auch über Kampfjets der Kanzler hat die
klare Maßgabe Schritt für Schritt und
insofern werden wir sehen wie sich das
jetzt entwickelt ich glaube das
Wichtigere wird in von vielen Staaten
jetzt auch so definiert das erstmal die
Munition und die Logistik für das
vorhandene da sein muss und das ist ja
gar nicht so leicht wie wir sehen noch
mal zur Gesellschaft der Krieg verändert
ja auch Umfragen zu Waffenlieferungen
zum Beispiel wie wichtig nimmt denn die
Ampel die Sorgen der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
also man muss ihn unterstellen dass sie
das sehr wichtig nehmen der Kanzler
betont das ja weil jeder Gelegenheit
deswegen auch seine Erklärung er geht
langsam vor was ihm als Zaudern und
zögern ja vorgeworfen wird er sagt
Schritt für Schritt es ist ein
klares Ziel dass er immer wieder
kommuniziert er will auf keinen Fall
Kriegspartei werden er will auf keinen
Fall dass die NATO Kriegspartei wird und
dennoch muss man ja sehen hat sich die
Ampel hat sich die SPD hat sich Olaf
Scholz unglaublich weit bewegt also man
muss ja sehen wo die einzelne Parteien
herkommen und die SPD von einer pro
russischen
friedensorientierten Partei liefert
jetzt schwere Waffen das ist ein sehr
weiter Weg innerhalb eines Jahres
vieles was die Regierung macht steht
nicht im Koalitionsvertrag der ja in
Teilen noch offen ist so muss man das
sagen ist das gut oder schlecht für
Deutschland
der Koalitionsvertrag ist im Prinzip ja
im Moment noch ich will nicht sagen auf
Eis gelegt aber das erste Jahr war ja
geprägt von der Krise alle die hier auch
im Saal sitzen Robert Habeck Olaf Scholz
hatten wir im Grunde jetzt nur mit der
Krise zu tun
dennoch kann man ja jetzt schon sehen
dass es jetzt auch die Bemühungen gibt
den Koalitionsvertrag umzusetzen da sind
ja viele Reformprogramme drin und das
was wir erlebt haben mit dem Kampf per
Brief zwischen Harbeck und Lindner die
sich ja jetzt um das Geld streiten also
nehmen wir neue Schulden auf um den
Koalitionsvertrag und die ganzen
Reformen die man sich vorgestellt hat
umzusetzen oder hält man die
Schuldenbremse ein und sagt wir müssen
bei dem bestehenden kürzen und das wird
die große Auseinandersetzung sein jetzt
den nächsten Zeit da Kanzler reißt heute
Abend noch weiter nach Indien sie werden
ihn begleiten Annalena bärburg ist
derzeit in den USA bei der UN wagen wir
noch einen Blick etwas weiter in die
Zukunft wie wirkt sich denn der Krieg
auf internationale Bündnis aus auf alte
und neue Allianzen fundamental also
die Regierung sucht eine neue
multipolare Welt das der Versuch jetzt
Indien einzubeziehen stärker der Kanzler
hat ja zum G7 auch verschiedene Staaten
eingeladen unter erkennt man auch gleich
die Schwierigkeiten denn natürlich viele
Länder Indien Südafrika Brasilien
Eigenheim gewohnt nicht weit weg von der
Straße nach Kiel
an jeden Tag war halt die Militärtechnik
schon unterwegs hier waren sehr nah
daran und haben eben diese
Kettenfahrzeuge hatte gehört und das ist
ein sehr unangenehm ich höre ihn bis
heute und ich wünsche niemanden dass er
das Hören muss
Telefon gesagt ähm es sind Panzer
unterwegs
reichen der Westen steht geschlossen an
der Seite der Ukraine wie lange das
nötig sein wird weiß ein Jahr nach
Kriegsbeginn
niemand doch im Schloss Bellevue gab es
heute einmal mehr das Versprechen dass
ich die Ukraine auch weiterhin auf
Deutschland verlassen kann wir
verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle und
verweisen gern auf den Livestream der
ZDF heute dort wird die hier im Schloss
laufende Podiumsdiskussion komplett
übertragen herzlichen Dank für Ihr
Interesse tschüss und auf Wiedersehen